Mike Pereira former head of NFL reps and
Fox rules analyst fresh back from New
Orleans calling into the show how are
you Mike I am great rich how are you I'm
doing fine okay
so let's walk through it what do you
think's going on in our River ons world
right now well it's not a good world to
be in I'm telling you he's getting heat
from everywhere including from upstairs
in the league office it's you take two
games championship games that ended in
overtime you know should have been a
grand day for the league regardless of
the fact that maybe some people don't
like you know the overtime play with
only one team getting the ball I was as
was the case with the Patriots but the
talk is all about officiating and that's
not what the league wants and the talk
has been all about really officiating
for the last two years and and replays
been a huge part of that and you know we
got an interesting player here in the
mix and that's Sean Payton who is on the
competition committee and is going to go
into those meetings starting in February
at the combine with his guns loaded and
he's a tough guy and he's gonna want to
walk out of that meeting in February and
then the follow up meeting in March with
something that will address what
happened you know at the end of their
game so I think we're on the verge of
maybe taking a leap forward I hope we're
on the verge of taking a leap forward
and finding a way to correct mistakes
like yesterday in 20 seconds and if you
can do that and and really kind of
really kind of take a bold step and
looking how to do that by taking an
eighth official and putting him as a
member of a crew in a booth with replay
equipment with just he and a technology
person with them and allow him to just
get on the horn - he has communication
the Bill of innovation to immediately
say after the first replay bill that was
passed
I'm your crew member I called the sky
judge you know Bill vinovich that was
pass interference at the six yard line
it was also hitting the defenseless
receiver
by the way which both get enforced take
the ball put it at the three first down
play on goal I think we're gonna have to
look at doing something like that to
eliminate these types of misses well you
know as Mike as you know I have opinions
and not only I not really opinions I've
got suggestions because I'm not just
gonna rail on something without offering
a solution I like that idea for the
final two minutes but you can't have
some unnamed unknown official sitting up
in a booth somewhere calling down when a
flag hasn't been thrown if you've got
fans in the stands looking for a flag
and they're going crazy and then all of
a sudden something buzzes down you might
think that somebody is is is reacting
under pressure based on what a crowd did
or not you've got to have outside of it
of an ability to challenge it you've got
to have it it's got to be a coach's
challenge initiated unless it's in the
last two minutes but everything should
be reviewable and anything should be
reviewable Mike well I don't think I
agree with you I don't think it has to
be a challenge and I'm not talking about
a hidden guy I mean I'm talking about an
eighth member of the crew no I know but
might be and I I think listen you've got
you've got crowd reaction inside of two
minutes to where you're are you
influencing the replay official upstairs
to stop the game to take another look I
mean I don't know if that's a relevant
argument in my mind all I want to do is
to figure out how to correct obvious
mistakes obvious mistakes and do it
without stopping the game for three
minutes and and and listen technology's
not going to get worse and officiating
is not going to get better
I mean it's so damn tough as it is right
now so you've got to look at the
technology that is available and the
speed that you can get it and see if you
can do something if it was me I would go
to the committee and I would say look at
let's not make hasty decisions here you
know let's let's use the 64 preseason
games that we have prior to the 2019
season and let's experiment with this
let's put an eighth official in this
booth
let's let him officiate the game as the
eighth member of the crew and just like
the crew gets together when there's a
block in the back call and somebody has
a different angle he just he's just
another member here and let's see if we
can correct the correct the obvious
mistakes and if it works in 64 games
then let's say in 2019 we put it in the
playoffs to ensure that it doesn't
happen and then if it works maybe then
adopted in 2020 going forward for all
games so you just think we've got to
look forward and really kind of change
how we have approached officiating and
technology to make it better but you
might without extending the game you
know that's it now you keep saying that
Mike prayer you throughout years I have
been saying let's make everything and
anything reviewable and you're like well
that's gonna extend the game it's gonna
be too long that's why I'm at least
saying it's got to be initially
initiated from the coaching sidelines
let's take a look at that I saw a
holding and then put an actual limit on
that so not only do you can maintain a
human element to officiating which i
think is important even fans would agree
that there's got to be some of that but
let's make sure that it comes from the
coaches you see an actual red challenge
flag come out and say that should have
been holding that should have been
passed interference that should have
been this as opposed to an an eighth
official that we're not seeing okay and
then we're suddenly getting some sort of
call out of nowhere on something that we
didn't see like now suddenly there's
gonna be an illegal contact that gets
missed that that's in the second quarter
that suddenly is gonna get called I
think people are gonna go absolutely
insane let's not use it for every play
but let's make everything reviewable
under the actual construct that we
already have in terms of a finite number
of challenges well I mean I just I see I
don't think they'll do that I mean I
think that's out of the question and I
just can't see them ever adopting the
Bill Belichick thing where let's end
Rich Eisen thing but let the coach
challenge everything because that that's
going to lead to that's gonna lead the
even longer games than if you did it the
way that I'm proposing to do it because
everybody says well
you know what we're not we don't want to
give the coaches more challenges well
you're giving them more challenges
because look at it now I mean coaches
don't have to challenge a turnover they
don't have to challenge a play that's
ruled you know a score and so you only
have about one point three coaches
challenges a game let them challenge
everything and we know that under the
current system they get to challenges
and they're gonna get them both right
they get a third so it might go one
point to the to five
you know challenges a game I just I just
don't see them I don't see the committee
doing that I see them looking at
something something I think less
dramatic and I know that you're talking
about the official that can't be seen
but you know I just think that they they
could take some smaller steps to maybe
correct maybe correct six things in the
time it would take you know for you know
them to correct to in actual replay
challenge situations right I just find
it hard to you know I you know I've you
look you view things through the lens of
a former official former head of NFL
refs for somebody who's in the league
office I put myself in the in the shoes
of a fan or on the couch of a fan and
I'm like sitting there thinking is there
a flag on the play
okay no flags now I'm gonna sit there
think okay is there a flag on the flight
no flags is there a flag from the booth
ah no flag from the booth that play now
stands I think that would just drive
some fans nuts but let's just in the
time we have remaining Mike Pereira Fox
Sports lead a head analyst of
officiating of Fox Sports I did that
just to piss Dean Blandino off to give
you that
let's give let's give some Saints fans
some clarity and potentially a pound of
flesh here does somebody lose their job
over this you know no why not well I
mean so you've got the guys through 15
15 games on the of the regular season
and a playoff game previously to this
you have guys that performed at the
highest level the highest level and so
that breaks down to one play at the end
of the game where they make a bad miss
it is a bad miss so you're gonna fire
them you're gonna fire two of your best
because they missed a call I don't think
you'd do that
you take a look why and do you maybe
think about some ramifications of you
know of a fine of some course like that
I get worried about that because once
you start finding officials for calls
that they don't make you're going to
lead them into call and really
ticky-tack stuff because they're going
to be afraid of a fine and so I think
you have to look at the whole body of
work you know that a guy performs during
the course of the season and if it is
bad and if he was a if he was what they
call the Tier three official and he made
a mistake like that in a championship
game you know then maybe I consider it
but tier three officials the ones that
are performed badly all year don't even
smell the playoffs
and so I would have a hard time looking
at the overall strength of my program
firing two guys who performed great over
the last couple of years and especially
this year you know I hate to admit it
but I've seen wide open receivers drop
passes and but and at big and at big
times I've seen defensive lineman line
up offsides on and then the play ends up
in an interception do you fire him I
think that's being a little bit
unreasonable ok so then let me ask you a
couple more questions here how do they
miss it I mean walk me through what the
case I mean how does that get missed by
everybody I can't I can't you know I
look at mechanics and what we always
talk about you know you talk about at
the snap man zone ball on passing plays
you've got five eligible receivers
you've got five officials around the two
in the line of scrimmage and the three
deep each have an official and so coming
off the line you go man you have a ball
you have a man you have a receiver that
you've got to clear the line of
scrimmage and then he goes into zone
whatever receiver comes into your zone
you take him and then when the ball goes
in the air everybody goes ball and to me
there were three officials to primarily
that had perfect looks of this and they
froze I mean I think that you know this
whole notion of you know subconsciously
you know trying to make the big call
they're never told directly at all to
let them play never but I think once you
get into the you know the playoffs like
this teams do play a little
better and you you know you want to stay
away from the ticky tack stuff that you
may have called earlier I don't know but
it's it's inexcusable I mean I can't I
can't offer anything to defend them in
this situation hi I've always felt like
if it's a bang-bang play that you're
better off not calling it this was not a
bang-bang play and this was a defender
that was not playing the ball this was a
defender that went high and made contact
to the head or neck area and nothing
came out of that nothing came out of
that from any one of the three and it's
gonna they're gonna live with that I'm
you know not as long as the Saints fans
and the same players are gonna have to
live with it because you know they'll be
back on the field of course next year
also but it's I can't I can't come up
with an excuse other than they just pros
and then their concept and then another
one for you here is Bill vinovich
speaking to a pool reporter afterwards
was asked about the play and he's like I
didn't see it I haven't seen it yet
which infuriated Saints fans even more
is there a possibility that the league
addresses on on on how things like this
are addressed for a fan base seeking
answers immediately Mike well you know
to me I'd like to see it quite frankly
address from the league office right
after the game instead of instead of the
official because you you know you did
the thing in real time and you they sent
a pool reporter in there and you haven't
even seen it on television yet so you
make yourself look worse they only let
the referee talk and you know and he'd
rightfully so he didn't he stays he
stays with the quarterback so that's not
his view at all but I I would agree that
you know that the response wasn't
appropriate to the act but to me I'd
rather I'd rather have I'd rather have
the league office as they addressed it
with Sean Payton afterwards apparently
in the conversations with al River on I
would rather there be some mechanism
that if there was a pool report
requested that it could actually go to
the league who at least could be
involved in the you know in the
statement well I mean it was on the
scoreboard and I understand that there
he's still an official trying to
officiate a game but there's no way he
didn't look
two more questions for you Mike Pereira
before I let you go
okay first one from the aides at the
rush I mean I'm always happy no I know
that I know that I'm you know I've got I
guess my own time constraints in a way
for the from the clock so the overtime
rules any Ani you think any appetite to
allow a team that's given up a touchdown
the chance to respond with the title
down no why nope I just think it went
long enough with the you know field go
field goal ending the game which was not
pleasant to anyone that they had a hard
time pushing this through to get it to
you know two possessions if the first
team did not score a touchdown
I think they pushed as far as they're
willing to go and I think the value of
being able to play defense and then
winning on a field goal you know in your
only opportunity to when you get the
ball back I think is enough and I just
don't see them moving on that at all so
I don't think they should really I mean
Patrick mahomes may be the MVP of this
league and even get a chance to touch
the football I understand don't blame me
don't blame me blame his defense then if
you want to but you know III think I
think the system is good I don't like
the college system I think it extends
the game in many cases too long I just I
just don't see that there will be a
movement there okay and last one for you
and and you know I'd love for you to
name a name Mike when you were the head
of NFL refs the toughest phone call you
had to make after one of your officials
blew something on the field to a coach
just like River on clearly had that's
got to be the toughest call he's ever
had to make the one he made to Sean
Payton yesterday Mike yeah well was
yours I mean the toughest situation I
ever got involved with really was the
Natha Tech play situation believe it or
not but it was the blood they missed a
call in the 49er giant game and when
when the the Giants attempted to kick a
field goal and it was blocked and then
they threw to it actually an eligible
receiver who had an ineligible number we
lost track of him and you know and it
should have been passive
ference which would have certainly kept
the Giants alive and probably propelled
them to the next round of the playoffs
that call that I had to make that the
Giants was a was a really tough call
would you think we broke down um
what's-his-name come on I do I blank and
his kid is the special teams coach for
this job it was Jim fossil he had a
colossal feel I had to call fossil I
called fossil and and was not a happy
man was not a happy man at all and then
I thought I wanted to make myself feel
better so my second call was to Mariucci
to tell him that I was going to make a
public statement that we we blew the
call and I I didn't want to give him the
impression that I was lessening the
value of their victory by admitting this
mistake and I called mooch and I said
mooch I just I just want you to know
that I'm gonna make this statement and
he said to me bummer publicly I know he
told you the same thing off the air off
mic - that was his response to my call
bummer bummer they made your life worse
didn't it when he said no I'd kind of
appreciated I might i always appreciate
it much anyway and i you knew it you
know how his mind works anyways and
there's something that he would say at
home or whatever bummer and hung up the
phone and on with wouldn't see he's
consistent story fantastic Mike great
chat with you great job as always we'll
see you down the line you got it you the
mats Mike prayer Fox Sports and chat
with him since day one of NFL Network
when he was the head of NFL refs do an
official review on total access the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience